can you say what does it take to
control a robot like what is the
control problem of a robot and in
general what is the robot
in your view like how do you think of
this uh system
what is a robot what is a robot i think
a lot of ridiculous questions no no it's
good um
i mean there's standard definitions of
combining
computation with some ability to do
mechanical work
i think that's gets us pretty close but
i think
robotics has this problem that once
things really work
we don't call them robots anymore like
your my dishwasher at home is
pretty sophisticated beautiful
mechanisms
there's actually a pretty good computer
probably a couple chips in there doing
amazing things we don't think of that as
a robot anymore
which isn't fair because then what
roughly it means that robots
robotics always has to solve the next
problem and
doesn't get to celebrate its past
successes i mean even factory room
floor robots are super successful
they're amazing
but that's not the ones i mean people
think of them as robots but they don't
if you if you ask what are the successes
of robotics
somehow it doesn't come to your mind
immediately so the definition of robot
is a
system with some level automation that
fails frequently
something like it's it's the computation
plus mechanical
work uh and uh unsolved problem
solved problem yeah so so from a
perspective of control
and uh mechanics dynamics what
what is a robot so there are many
different types of robots
the control that you need for uh
a jibo robot you know some some robot
that's sitting on your
countertop and and interacting with you
but not touching you for instance
is very different than what you need for
an autonomous car or an autonomous
drone it's very different than what you
need for a robot that's going to
walk or pick things up with its hands
right
my passion has always been for them
places where you're interacting more
you're doing more dynamic
interactions with the world so walking
now manipulation and the control
problems there are
are beautiful i think contact is one
thing that
differentiates them from many of the
control problems we've solved
classically
right like modern control grew up
stabilizing fighter jets that were
passively unstable and
there's like amazing success stories
from control all over the place
um power grid i mean there's all kinds
of it's it's it's
everywhere uh that we don't even realize
just like i ai is
now so you mentioned contact like
what's contact so an airplane
is of extremely complex system or a
spacecraft landing or whatever
but at least it has the luxury of
things change relatively continuously
that's an oversimplification but
if i make a small change in the command
i send to my actuator
then the path that the robot will take
tends to take a
change only by a small amount and
there's a feedback mechanism here
there's a feedback mechanism and
thinking about this as
locally like a linear system for
instance i can use
more linear algebra tools to study
systems like that
generalizations of linear algebra to to
these
smooth systems what is contact the
robot has something very discontinuous
that happens when it
makes or breaks when it starts touching
the world and even the way it touches or
the order of
contacts can change the outcome in
potentially
unpredictable ways not unpredictable but
complex ways i do think there's a little
bit of
people a lot of people will say that
contact is hard in robotics
even to simulate and i think there's a
little bit of a
there's truth to that but but maybe a
misunderstanding around that
so what is limiting is that when we
think about our robots when we write our
simulators
we often make an assumption that that
objects are rigid
and when it comes down you know that
they that their mass moves all
you know it stays in a constant position
relative to each other itself
um and and that leads to
some paradoxes when you go to try to
talk about rigid body mechanics and
contact
and so for instance if i have a
three-legged stool
with just imagine it comes to a point at
the
at the leg so it's only touching the
world at a point
if i draw my physics my high school
physics
diagram of this system then there's a
couple of things that i'm given by
by elementary physics i know if the
system if the table is at rest if it's
not moving
it's zero that means that the normal
force
all the forces are in balance so the
the force of gravity is being countered
by the forces that the ground is pushing
on my table legs i also know since it's
not rotating
that there that the moments have to
balance and since it can
in it's a three-dimensional table it
could fall in any direction
it actually tells me uniquely what those
three normal forces have to be
if i have four legs on my table
four-legged table
and they were perfectly machined to be
exactly the right same height and
they're set down and the table's not
moving
then the basic conservation laws don't
tell me
there are many solutions for the forces
that the ground could be putting on my
legs
that would still result result in the
table not moving
now the reason that seems fine i could
just pick one
but it gets funny now because if you
think about friction
what we what we think about with
friction is we our standard model says
the amount of force that you're that the
table will push back if i were to now
try to push my table sideways
i guess i have a table here
is proportional to the normal force
so if i have if i'm barely touching and
i push i'll slide but if i'm pushing
more and i
push i will slide less it's called
coulomb friction
is our standard model now if you don't
know what the normal force is on the
four legs
and you push the table then you don't
know
what the friction forces are going to be
right and so you can't actually tell
the laws just don't aren't explicit yet
about which way the table is going to go
it could veer off to the left it could
veer off to the right it could go
straight
so the rigid body assumption of contact
leaves us with some paradoxes which are
annoying for
for writing simulators and for writing
controllers
we still do that sometimes because soft
contact is
potentially harder numerically or
whatever and the best simulators do both
or do some combination of the two but
but anyways because of these kind of
paradoxes
there's all kinds of paradoxes in
contact
mostly due to these rigid body
assumptions it becomes very hard to like
write the same kind of control laws that
we've been able to be successful with
for like fighter jets we haven't been as
successful writing those controllers
for manipulation and so you don't know
what's going to happen at the point of
contact
at the moment of contact there are
situations absolutely where you
where our laws don't tell us so the
standard approach that's okay
i mean instead of having a differential
equation
you end up with a differential inclusion
it's called it's a set valued
equation it says that i'm in this
configuration i have these forces
applied on me
um and there's there's a set of things
that could happen
right and um and those aren't continuous
any i mean what uh
so when you're seeing like non-smooth
yep they're not only
not smooth but this is discontinuous
the non-smooth comes in when i make or
break a new contact first
or when i transition from stick to slip
so you typically have static friction
and then you'll start sliding and
that'll be a discontinuous change in
in velocity for instance especially if
you come to rest or
that's so fascinating okay so uh so what
do you what do you uh do
sorry i interrupted you um
what's the hope under so much
uncertainty about what's going to happen
what are you supposed to do i mean
control has an answer for this robust
control is one approach
but but roughly you can write
controllers which try to still
perform the right task despite all the
things that could possibly happen
the world might want the table to go
this way in this way but if i write a
controller
that pushes a little bit more and pushes
a little bit i can
certainly make the table go in the
direction i want
it just puts a little bit more of a
burden on the control system
right and this discontinuities do change
the control system
because the way we write it down right
now
every different control con
configuration
including sticking or sliding or parts
of my body that are in contact or not
looks like a different system and i
think of them i reason about them
separately or differently and the
combinatorics of that
blow up right so i just don't have
enough time to compute
all the possible contact configurations
of my humanoid
interestingly i i mean i'm a humanoid
i have lots of degrees of freedom lots
of joints
i only i've only been around for a
handful of years it's getting up there
but
i haven't had time in my life to visit
all of the states
in my system certainly all the contact
configurations
so if step one is to consider every
possible contact configuration that i've
i'll ever be in that's probably a
that's probably not a problem i need to
solve right
just a small attention what's the
contact configuration
what like just so we can uh
yeah enumerate what are we talking about
yeah how many are there
the simplest example maybe would be
imagine a robot with a flat
foot and we think about the phases of
gait
where the heel strikes and then the four
the front
toe strikes and then you can heal up toe
off
those are each different contact
configurations
i only had two different contacts but i
ended up with four different
contact configurations now of course i
might have
my my robot might actually have
bumps on it or other things so it could
be much more subtle than that right
but it's just even with one sort of box
interacting with the ground already
in in the plane has that many right and
if i was just even a 3d foot
then probably my left toe might touch
just before my right toe and
things get subtle now if i'm a dexterous
hand
and i go to talk about just grabbing a
water bottle if every
if i have to enumerate every possible
order
that my hand came into contact with the
with the bottle
then i'm dead in the water i might my
any approach that we were able to get
away with that in walking
because we mostly touch the ground
within a small number of points for
instance
and we haven't been able to get dextra's
hands that way
so i mean you've mentioned that
people think that contact is really hard
and that that's the reason
that robotic manipulation is problem is
really hard
is there any flaws in that
thinking so i think simulating contact
is one aspect i know people often say
that we don't
that one of the reasons that we have a
limit in robotics is because we do not
simulate contact accurately
in our simulators and i think that is
the extent to which that's true is
partly because our
simulators we haven't got mature enough
simulators
there are some things that are still
hard difficult that has
changed um
but but we actually we know what the
governing equations are they have some
foibles
like this indeterminacy but we should be
able to simulate them accurately
we have incredible open source community
in robotics but
it actually just takes a professional
engineering team a lot of work
to write a very good simulator like that
you